the story picks up sort of a few months
after the end of the first film
unexpectedly Kingsman is sort of
obliterating its bond and all of the
properties are decimated and so Merlin
and eggsy have to go on a kind of
fact-finding quest to piece together
what's happened
they are led to a sister organization
they didn't know they had in America
will be working side by side let's get
started
[Music]
seeing this movie in IMAX is going to be
a great experience fans of action it'll
be amazing to see on a really big screen
the point about IMAX is it's intense its
height it's incredibly detailed you're
totally immersed and I'm actually good
to see it with an audience and I think
movies like these are best share it with
others I would like to see it on an IMAX
screen and I mean that sincerely you're
under the water one minute you through
them from streets of London the next you
got miss Arthur you're up and down it's
quite a ride yeah it is I think if
there's anything that would lend itself
to a write back something is this
[Music]
you